purane parsley and sourdough crumbs a
kasi start with parsley root puree and a
cream of green parsley Christian homes
takes soup ingredients and turns them
into a dessert even dares to combine
cassis jelly and sour dough ice cream
with parsley and cranberries
yeah buddy let's try a lazier start over
I've worked hard the last three years
trying different ways to do things like
processing vegetables bonitas de esta
other things folks I'm not the first
person to look for new ways to broadly
people's horizons to try to repeatedly
challenged the firm ideas that we have
about classic dishes classic and create
fresh inspiration of annoyance of
everyone sue inspirion cucumber as a
dessert rather than a salad ingredient
pureed parsley made into a cream avocado
with soy mousse for dessert Christian
homes compositions are a gourmet treat
at the end of head chefs of ASEAN CEA's
menu mr. shyam Jose Iman and also given
me his it's always an extraordinary
thing when a chef or pastry chef breaks
new ground when he just doesn't say okay
well I'm going to make the hundreth warm
chocolate cake with orange segments but
instead tries to dessert with cucumber
and passion fruit when he combines
flavors that have never been combined
before and people think it won't work
but he does it anyway and it turns out
better than many classic dishes
such as the cauliflower dessert that's
on today's menu room Cosette shall
jellyfish a Saudi javed Isaiah gana
cauliflower is really sweet I always
like to start off with vegetables that
are sweet not bland but with a very
strong individual character and sweet
I've also worked with onion for me onion
was always a bit strange but when it's
processed into a mild honey it becomes a
really nice ingredient I can't serve it
directly as a dessert but I can use it
to adjust the flavor of another of my
desserts the cauliflower florets are
gently cooked and pureed then whom's
adds a bit of nutmeg and some white
chocolate
right seal grand seigneur alcohol you
want to come taste this town homes
kitchen colleagues are always the first
to taste his creations Nicki Phillies
decides I'd spitball I think it needs
more salt and pepper but all in all it's
good well I'm thinking we can put this
on the dessert menu goom's is creating a
cream of roasted cauliflower
pumpernickel crumbs barley and buckwheat
popcorn and dehydrated caramelized
cauliflower florets with that amount of
effort going into each dish it's no
wonder that his restaurant la mia only
offers two different desserts every
evening sonal any formal I don't know
myself it takes two or three days just
to prepare the ingredients honey
processes just can't be speeded on we
have to be careful to retain the
original flavors and get them just right
but I rushed the cooking process I'll
distort the taste any time when I
thoughtful navidad side of a cliff
townhomes restaurant is located right on
the beach on the island of suit the
crisp north sea air helps clear his mind
for new ideas for example in 2013 who
created a six course dessert menu the
dipping it's your first to see I could
see there's no scent definition for a
dessert the limit is when you strayed
too far into the area of warm cuisine
now too salty note the herbal notes and
the masculine tones become too
pronounced people start to think oh
that's just an appetizer there's a very
fine line and guns can smile I God
not every guest is happy to discover
cauliflower on the dessert menu but most
are curious the feedback though is
generally positive one thing is for sure
close townhomes desserts aren't
something you will forget in a hurry